The problem is that in some sense, the threat
is implausible. And it, and it, in a very
kind of real sense. So what's happened is that if you do fake out on me, if you
do cross that line, the idea that I will
then spend the rest of my days punishing you,
forgoing reward myself, right? Not taking the best response
against you, seems kind of crazy. Do you agree?
>> Yeah,
again, my ex-girlfriend. Yeah, I totally get this.
>> No, but no, I'm saying that nobody would do that.
>> Right, so it, it would be like being in a elevator with a stick of
dynamite and seeing that someone has a hundred
dollars and saying, give me your hundred dollars
or I'll blow us both up. That's not
really a reasonable threat because the alternative to
me not giving you a hundred dollars is,
you die, which seems probably not worth it.
>> That's right, so you could think about
the possibility of, okay, I'm going to not
give you the $100, you say that you're going to blow me up,
but you will hurt yourself more than you hurt me, so it won't
be a best response. Not blowing me up and just not getting the
$100 and leaving the elevator is better for you than blowing me up.
>> Right.
>> So that is an implausible threat. So the
way we formalize this idea, in the game theoretic
context, is to say that we're interested. A plausible
threat corresponds to something that's called a subgame perfect equilibrium.
>> Okay.
>> So subgame perfect means that each player is always taking a best
response, independent of the history. All right,
so let's actually look at a concrete
example here, let's imagine playing Grim Trigger,
against Tit for Tat. So my first
question to you is, are these two strategies in nash equilibrio with each other.
>> Yeah I guess so.
>> And why is that?
>> Because, the fact, if I'm playing Tit,
if one player is playing Tit for Tat
then the Grim Trigger thing doesn't matter anyway because both of you
are going to cooperate forever and it doesn't make any sense to deviate.
>> Right, so any strategy that I could choose that's different than
Grim Trigger is going to on average do no better, possibly worse.
>> Right.
>> So I might as well stick with Grim Trigger
and Tit for Tat has the same kind of feeling about
it, that, it's cooperating with Grim. And any, it can't
really do anything better so it might as well do that.
>> Right.
>> So the next question to ask is.
Are these two strategies in a subgame perfect equilibrium with
each other? And the way that you actually test that, is
you say, well, they are not subgame perfect. If there's
some history of actions that we could feed to these machines,
so that, so that, you know, here's, here's what Grim
is doing. It's, it's some, some sequence of cooperates and defects,
and here's what Tit for Tat is doing. It's some sequence
of cooperates and defects. And once we've reached some particular point.
Is it the case that one or the other of these
machines is not taking a best response that it could actually change
it's behavior away from, what the machine says and do better then
what the machine says. If that is the case then it's not
subgame perfect but if it's the case of all histories. They're
always taking a best response. Then, it is subgame perfect. So, so
do you see a, a sequence of, of moves that these two
players can take where one or the other of them is not
going to be doing a best response?
>> It's, can take, right? As opposed to, will take.
>> I don't understand.
>> Yeah, I'm not sure I do either. That's
why I asked the question. It's not a, you know
made up history, it's like an actual set of
moves that are consistent with Grim and Tit for Tat.
>> No no, no no, so it is, it is not necessarily. So we know that
if we actually play these against each other
the only history that we're going to see, is.
>> Cooperate forever.
>> Right, Grim
is going to do cooperate cooperate cooperate cooperate,
Tit for Tat is going to do cooperate cooperate
cooperate cooperate. And so they are, and
everything's fine. The question is, can we actually
go in and alter, the history, so that one or the other in the machines
could take a better action than the one that the machine tells it to take.
>> Yeah if Tit for Tat, ever does defect.
>> Alright, so let's take a look at that. So, let's say,
on the first move Grim cooperates and Tit for Tat defects. Okay, so let's
say that, that's the moment in time. What will the machines do at this point?
>> Well, at this point the and next time
step, Tit for Tat will cooperate and Grim will defect.
>> Good and then thereafter.
>> Grim will always defect.
>> And then Tit for Tat will always defect.
>> Right.
>> So the
pay of that Grim gets at this point is
going to be, well initially high but then very very low.
>> Mm-hm.
>> On the other hand could Grim have
changed it's behavior to do better than this?
>> Yeah. Just by doing just, by choosing to cooperate.
>> By choosing to cooperate, so it sort of
ignore the fact that, that Tit for Tat did the
defect, and instead do a cooperate here, then Grim would
do better. So the idea is that Grim is making
a threat, but when it comes time to
actually follow through on that threat, it's actually doing
something that is worse for itself. Than what
it would do otherwise. Do, do you see that?
>> I do.
>> So is it subgame perfect? No. And the proof
of that is exactly, exactly what you said, Take, take
a look at this history. Here's a history where Grim
would not be willing to actually follow through on its threat.
>> Right.
>> So it's an implausible threat, and that's
bad. So maybe we've now just undone all
the awesomeness that we had done.
>> No.
>> Well maybe. I mean the awesomeness was hey look we can actually
get machines that are in nash
equilibrium and they're cooperative in, in prisoner's
dilemma so they're actually kind of doing the right thing. And, turns out well
they are but they're, depending on this notion of implausible threats to do it.
>> Mm, how should I feel about that?
>> Well, let's see if we can fix it.
>> Okay.